hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast treasure treasure optimizing
titration electrodes and consumables
presented by Jessica McVeigh Technical
Support Specialists metro and lori
stafford product manager for titration
met Rome I'm Alexis Krause of laberd's
and I will be our moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
leverage and sponsored by metro meu sa
Metro offers a complete line of
analytical laboratory and process
systems for titration on chromatography
electrochemistry and spectroscopy from
routine moisture analysis to
sophisticated aniion in keishon
quantification mushroom can help you
develop your method and configure the
optimal system for more information
about our sponsor visit wwm at Rome comm
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left to
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen our speakers will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January of
2019 you will receive an email from
Roberts letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please join me in welcoming Jessica
McVeigh and Lauri Stafford
I will now turn the presentation over to
them we're going to be talking about
optimizing titration electrodes and
really kind kind of trying to put some
parameters around do we trash it or you
know do we need to replace it or do we
keep it repair it so let's go ahead and
get started so you know I kind of like
to start this obsession ah by saying you
know we all have that junk drawer right
you
at home or at your desk or maybe
sometimes it's in the lab and you know
it's that kind of that safe place where
we like to stash things we're unsure if
we're going to need it again and just
really aren't ready to part with it when
it comes to replacing titration or pH
electrodes we often uncover a bad habit
of simply just adding the retired
electrode to a drawer full of the youth
devices and so you know here we're going
to ask you know why do we insist on
hanging on to the electrodes long after
we've replaced them sometimes I have to
do within certainty right we're just not
exactly sure how to troubleshoot it or
really what to focus on when it comes to
electrode health sometimes it's a matter
of really just needing to optimize
resources in the lab so unless that
glass breaks we're just going to deal
with the symptoms of maybe a slowing
response or a noisy signal when deep
down we probably know that that
electrode has been in use long past its
lifetime and then sometimes there's a
possibility that well maybe I can pull
this electrode back out of the drawer
sometimes and use it as a backup if
something goes wrong and so in today's
session we're going to work through some
of those reasonings and hopefully
hopefully provide you with a better
thought pathways understanding how to
diagnose your electrode better we'll add
some clarity around best practices for
maintenance and care as well then I'm
going to pass our session over to Jeff
chemic they her focus here at macho and
like Trevor said is providing support so
day in and day out she's taking calls
and emails helping labs troubleshoot and
making recommendations and so through
her experience she's developed five
simple ways to know when to replace your
electrode and then lastly maybe you have
a drawer folded electrodes and you're
just not sure how to dispose of them so
we'll wrap up the session today with a
couple of additional resources and one
of them will be how to go about making
that disposable in a responsible manner
so let's get to it part of understanding
how to troubleshoot means you need to
know how the electrode works even if
you've been in the lab for years this
section will be helpful we often take
for granted the workings of just a
simple electrode and and while titration
and pH measurements aren't complex per
se getting a refresher of this knowledge
always helps us create a clear pathway
when we start to think about diagnosing
the system so let's start with the
dictionary definition right when we're
talking potentiometry we're using a
lecture that produces a voltage that is
logarithmically dependent on the
concentration of a selected ion okay
we're talking about if' news here
whether that's a pH electrode or other
ion selective sensor common examples
being fluoride chloride copper lead and
even surfactant ion selective electrodes
other sensors are radix electrode and
maybe a metal ring combination
electorate commonly constructed of
silver or platinum so all of these are
electrodes that give us a voltage that's
dependent on a concentration of a
substance in our sample okay
so ground level if we look at what is
needed to make the measurement the same
four components are needed to complete
the circuit for every sample for every
example rather so we need two measuring
sensors we need an indicator or
measuring electrode that give the
potential dependent on the composition
of the sample solution okay
the other is a reference electrode so
this will supply a constant potential
which is as independent as possible from
the sample solution okay next we'll need
a meter or other device to collect that
signal and convert it into something
that makes sense to us
and then lastly we've got to have a
sample to complete that full circuit
more common
today we see combined electrode systems
and this is really because it's more
convenient to have both components built
into a single sensor it takes up a lot
less space in our sample and is less
dependent on sample homogenization and
and simply reduces the surface area
exposed to the sample this means we
basically have left to worry about in
regards to cross contamination as we
move from sample to sample
so after this session you may go back
into the lab and wonder what type of
electrode system do I have simply look
to see if you have a glass bulb and a
fill port those are the easiest telltale
signs of a combination electrode system
now if you call in for support and you
end up getting Jessica on the phone
we're likely going to start asking
questions about the electrode first and
there are some common terms used to
navigate the different sections of the
electrode and knowing these will help
you get to the cost fastest okay so
since it's most common we're going to be
talking about the combination of the
lecture now the general parts of the
sensor are the electrode head and this
is where the electronic connections are
made and definitely an area we want to
protect from getting wet with sample or
titration reagents following it down
next we have the fill port or a refill
opening so the reference electrode
system needs constant care and feeding
with electrolyte solution and this is
where we access that the shaft or glass
shaft or sometimes plastic depending on
the type of electrode it's just the main
body of the electrode and while we want
to keep this area and below rinse of the
sample between measurements there's no
actual measurement or any magic
happening here right but but give yours
a look in the lab get familiar with how
it's supposed to look when it's healthy
that way if it does endure any cracks
you know you'll know how to see those
right away because those will affect how
the electrode works lastly is the
electrode tip this is the sensitive
measuring area of the electrode
basically where the important that
happens the electrode tip is composed of
the diaphragm we
is part of the reference electrode and
the glass membrane or balled which is
the actual sample where the actual
sample measurements occur in application
instructions our general discussions you
may be asked hey is the tip of the
electrode submerged that means this
entire area so this is the portion of
the electrode that must be in contact
with the sample throughout the
measurement or the titration now because
of the importance of each of those that
membrane and diaphragm we're going to go
one level deeper with each of those
portions so the image you see on your
screen now is a cross-section of the
membrane bulb so again this is the ion
sensitive part of the electrode the
membrane is constructed of special glass
and this is the area in the image where
you see the silicate skeleton that
contains kind of the lithium ions and
among other things floating around in
there okay on either side of that glass
there are two very thin gel like
hydration layers so in your image those
are the gray kind of Halfmoon shapes so
thinking about the outer hydration
layers this is what actually comes into
contact with our sample solution while
the inner layer comes into contact with
the electrolyte solution so when the
electrode comes into contact with a
sample solution H+ ions are either
diffused into or out of the gel layer
leaving behind a charge so think for
example just maybe on the right hand
side we're looking at an alkaline
example so in that solution the H+ ions
diffuse out of the gel layer and a
negative charge is left on the outer
side layer of the gel that hydration
layer since the glass electrode has an
internal buffer and that had the
constant pH value the potential at the
inner surface of the membrane remains
constant during the measurement so
bringing it full circle we're able to
get the total membrane potential as a
result of the difference between the
inner and the outer charges
so electrode membrane or ball we've got
that now how it's working now after this
session you may go and look in that
infamous electro door and notice that
not all of the bulbs look alike that's
actually on perfect the membrane can be
made of different types of specialty
glass to help improve performance and
certain types of samples so just like
you would use a different sample
container for a non acquiesce sample
versus say something just like water
different glass material is more optimal
depending on the sample type the easiest
way you can tell that there's difference
or something going on is just to look at
the color of the glass so you see the
images on the left-hand side of your
screen that gives you some examples so
glue some is clear some is yellow you
also may notice that sometimes they have
different shapes so this is a simple way
to make sure that we can get the entire
electro design into the sample so on the
right you'll see some different designs
so the top one is kind of a needle or a
taper design and this is really helpful
if you've got semi solid or thicker kind
of more viscous samples so think yoghurt
or a soft cheese or something you may
also run into an application where you
don't have a lot of sample you still
need to make these measurements for that
there is a micro cylinder this bulb
measures only three millimeters across
and this really small electrode only
requires 20 millimeters of immersion
depth so depending on what your sample
cup looks like this can be very very
small the last one on your screen is
interesting because the entire sensors
measuring surfaces are actually on the
bottom so this means that only the
bottom needs to be in contact with a
sample to take a pH measurement so here
we see this design being helpful for
applications where we're looking at
maybe a pH measurement of a textile or a
leather fabric or even making pH
measurements on skin
so alright let's shift gears back to the
reference electrode and take a closer
look at what's happening with the
diaphragm so the diaphragm just in
general is responsible for providing a
constant outflow of the electrolyte into
the sample that means the electrolyte
must go into the sample solution we want
that inner electrolyte solution to
slowly drain into the sample as we're
making measurements it obviously will be
draining so so that you don't see it
with a human eye but it will be leaving
the electrodes this happens due to
simple hydro static gravity driven
pressure so the only way this occurs is
if that fill port is open so write that
down during measurement you must unplug
the fill port at the top of the
electrode remember the measuring circuit
we talked about earlier if you don't
open the still port you're not allowing
that circuit to be completed by allowing
that electrolyte just low so if we focus
at the image on your screen you'll see a
couple of scenarios to help us
understand the importance of keeping the
electrolyte solution topped off if we
focus on side a here this is what
happens when we let the electrolyte
level drain to very low levels when we
put that electrode into the sample
solution the pressure on the outside of
the electrode is greater than the
pressure on the inside so what happens
is we have the sample creep follow that
red arrow creep up into the inside of
the electrode and then what happens is
we are contaminating the reference
chamber and ruining the electrode beyond
beyond repair here looking at side C
simply keeping the electrolyte solution
topped off allows the solution to be
flowing in the right direction so that
yellow arrow we want that one to be
bigger we want the electrolyte to be
flowing out so really the take-home here
is keeping the electrolytes filled up
properly is key to not only a properly
working electrode but also preventing
damage
just like the membrane bulb you may
notice a couple of different designs for
the diaphragm the ceramic pin may be
considered a little bit more of an older
generation so that's the electrode image
on the left you see a very tiny red
circle around that pin diaphragm and for
the most part the affixed ground joint
or the electrode to the right is more
more commonly what you'll see so the
diaphragm is the actual entire frosted
section kind of in the boodle there so
that entire it goes all the way around
the electrode that's where the
electrolyte will will drain into the
sample regardless of design here the
functions are the same we want to slowly
ensure contact between the sample and
the reference electrode via the
electrolyte solution when it comes to
using them
the only difference you'll need to
understand is the impact of stirring and
that's the graph on your screen if we
put both of these electrodes into a
stirring sample and watch the signal we
see a fairly steady response okay once
we shut the stirring off you can see the
ground joint diaphragm maintains a
steady signal while the ceramic pin
starts to trail off this comes down to
just an ergonomics so the ceramic pin is
on one side of the electrode and so that
causes a little bit of change and how
that signal is picked up all is really
important to know here is that when it
comes to construction of the diaphragm
the ground joint offers a really good
solution that's less dependant on
stirring okay
so we keep moving here by taking a look
at the pH scale and really consider for
a moment what we're asking of these
electrodes that you'll see on the left
the standard pH scale that ranges from
zero to 14 on the right you'll see what
th measurement means in terms of the
concentration of H+ ions so you'll
notice at very high pH is there are very
few h+ ions in the solution basically
this becomes very difficult range to
measure pH and since our pH electrode
you should basically think of
as an eye on sensitive electrode for h+
ions okay a few slides back we talked
about all of the H+ ion exchange and
potential generation that is occurring
at the glass bulb or the membrane as we
get into samples of higher pH values we
run into what is called the alkali error
range and strongly alkaline solutions
standard electrode negative measurement
errors due to the potential contribution
of other alkali ions so think potassium
sodium lithium we'll be getting to these
higher pH values there are so few h+
ions in the solution that not only does
the pH D difficult to measure but we've
got those other +1 ions contributing so
rather than an ideal straight linear
relationship across the pH measuring
range pH values can appear to be lower
the keeps are kind of ensuring that
you're getting accurate results in the
scenarios make sure using an electrode
with a membrane designed to handle these
pH ranges if you're working in this
sample range check the color of the
membrane glass mushrooms electrodes are
infused with ions to give the bulb
characteristics to rich down these
difficult samples so in this in this
instance yellow glass is designed to
perform well in these high pH scenarios
next up let's talk a little bit about
calibration and why it's needed so think
of a simple image on your screen now is
a two point calibration so we have two
buffers give two potentials that's your
u1 and u2 at two pH values pH one and pH
two so going back to the beginning the
potential of a measuring electrode can
always only be given relative to that of
the reference electrode so in order to
compare the system the electrode zero
point something that we define as zero
millivolts for pH seven we need to use
that and also we use the electrode slope
which is given to us through the Nernst
equation and that is just theoretically
defined as 59 millivolt per one pH unit
now
those are ideal values and they'll
change as a result of the aging glass
membrane or a change in the diaphragm
system so for this reason a pH meter or
device whatever you're making the
calibration or pH measurements with must
be adapted to the characteristics of the
electrode so when we calibrate we're not
actually making any changes to the
electrode birthday we're adapting this
system to the electrode conditions so
all of us to say make sure we're
calibrating at regular intervals and
using fresh buffer solutions do you
often hear on when you talk about pH
temperature comes up and it's not
important to have the entire Nernst
equation memorized here you might earn
some bonus points though but I think we
can break it down more simply basically
what you need to know is that
temperature influences the pH value if
an electrode is calibrated at 25 C then
it should be capable of a linear
measurement throughout the whole pH
range and provide correct results
however it is the electrode is use if
the electrode is used at a different
temperature the electrode slope will
change and possibly the electrode
zero-point so on your screen now we see
example if you look at the blue line so
the ideal sample measured at 25 C if we
take that same measurement and say it
chilled down we'll get you can see the
shift from either side there one of the
results of the calibration is the
electrode zero point sometimes you may
hear this referred to as pH zero
intercept or the asymmetry potential
essentially what we're looking at here
is so we've got that theoretical zero
millivolts reading at a pH of seven in
the real world we would make an
adjustment from that theoretical value
and that is the asymmetry potential
general
operation recommendations use a
three-point or three buffer calibration
and and when you're selecting buffers to
make your calibration select ones that
bracket the pH range of the samples that
you're measuring it's important to use
fresh buffers especially in the higher
concentration ranges anything over pH
nine will start to absorb co2 and that
will alter the value and then lastly
make sure we're selecting the right
buffer in the instrument and either
enter that temperature measurement
manually or set it to automatic or
continuous for temperature correction to
maximizing the life of your lecture
there are a few tips that I'd like to
share with you that can help improve the
electrode life between measurements
titrations and when you're first putting
the electrode into use you should always
rinse the electrode first with distilled
or di water if that's not enough to
clean it properly so you're working with
a really difficult sample you can use a
detergent or solvent depending on the
kind of contamination after that always
rinse it again with that distilled or
DIY in order to recondition that
electrode the conditioning time can also
depend on the cleaning time so depending
on on what what you cleaned it with like
say if you used a solvent that means
you've likely stripped away that
hydration layer on the membrane and we
need to allow it to condition in water a
little bit longer it's also very
important to avoid as much as you can
bare wiping the glass membrane with the
tissue a lot of times I know we like to
try to get that last drop off of the
bulb or we feel like we could really get
it cleaned will do better but in reality
this practice can actually cause
mechanical and micro damages which can
change the property of the electrode so
micro scratches in the membrane can can
manifest as a noisy signal from your
electrode also you can load the
electrode electrostatically and once
you've charged
the electrode it can be very difficult
to to regenerate it so try as much as
possible to avoid that if you need to
clean the electrode you know we've got a
couple I've got a couple kind of buckets
here for so routine cleaning really
consists of periodically emptying the
electrolytes on the electrode just use a
plastic dropper and kind of suck the
electrolyte out of that fill port go
ahead and rinse the chamber with fresh
electrolyte never never fill this body
with water you don't want to put water
in there
I know logic tells us oh it's salty in
there and I know water will just
dissolve those crystals and rip them
right out but this is actually a really
horrible practice for the reference act
that's in there so even if it takes a
couple of passes fill it and empty it
and then fill it and empty it again in
the end always refill and store the
electrode with the electrolyte with the
deep cleaning this may be required if
the diaphragm has become clogged and the
electrode may require a deeper cleaning
so I mean if you if you've got a sample
that might have whipped up into that
frosted glass area of the electrode this
might be helpful so what you're going to
do here is empty the electrolyte out of
the body of the electrode and place the
sensor into a cleaning solution
overnight let it sit overnight the
cleaning solution will have kind of
whipped up into that diaphragm but not
up into the chamber the next day fill
the chamber with the proper electrolyte
solution and leave the fill port open so
we want the electrolyte to drain and
completely flush that diaphragm back out
when it comes to selecting a cleaning
solution that will really depend on what
your contaminant is what you're working
with for example if you have silver
precipitates those typically respond
really well to a 7% diarrhea and 0.1
molar HCL cleaning solution if you're
dealing with some really stubborn
protein deposits we can remove those
with a one
pepsin in 0.1 molar HCL for fact that
oils simply use a silica suitable
solvent so try something like IPA if
that works you may have to go with
toluene or a xylene or something so here
a quick word on electro storage for me
account of the rule of thumb here is
just to think about the two parts of the
electrode and how they want to be stored
right so you have the membrane of the
diaphragm it always comes down to how
those need to be cared for the membrane
what's key here that it really just
can't dry out so ideally it would love
to be stored in distilled water if we
separately think about the diaphragm
this is a really concentrated salt
solution inside of there and so ideally
it would love to be stored in reference
electrolyte
well we can't do both here right so the
key answer here is is to get that
perfect balance and that's found in just
a simple electrode storage solution so
this formula is specially designed to
quench both of those so we have to
provide enough hydration for the glass
bulb and enough salt to keep the
diaphragm moving additionally it has
some added antifungal properties and
this will help prevent algae growth and
contamination if the electrode is stored
for extended periods of time we often
get the question well why can't I just
store it in my KCl electrolyte solution
so the graph on your screen now will
really help you understand and explain
why we don't recommend this if you focus
on the blue line this represents a pH
measurement taken using an electrode
that was you that was stored in KCl sole
solution give me so what we see is that
the potassium ions have taken up
residence in the electrode membrane and
it took up to a thousand up to the 1000
second mark that we're looking at 15
just over 15 minutes here for those K
plus ions to leave the membrane and
allow us to get to an equal abraded pH
measurement the red line represents the
measurement taken from an electrode that
was stored in
buffered the the electrode storage
solution so you see the pH measurement
response is very quick and it's very
stable so really the take-home message
here is keep your electrode and store
solution especially for those overnight
storages and you'll be immediately ready
to make measurements the next day if
you're sitting there listening now and
cringing a little bit because you've
been storing your electrode and KCl
don't fret you really here will just
need some front-end conditioning time to
make sure that you're getting a setting
accurate signal so get that electrode
bulb stirring in water to let it refresh
and then from here on out let's look at
using an electrode storage solution
you're not entirely sure what
electrolyte storage and cleaning
solutions it's all just kind of a little
bit you know it's a lot of information
right now this fit kit can be very
helpful so this will get you off the
ground and price and provide a good
healthy first step ensuring your
electrodes have that proper care I'm
feeding so next up I'd like to pass the
session over to our technical expert
Jessica McKnight she has five simple
tips to share with you Jessica hi
everyone as Lori mentioned earlier in
the beginning of the presentation it may
be hard to let go some of your
electrodes however I'm here to help I
have five simple tips to determine when
it's time to let go and dispose of your
old electrodes okay number one check
response time the response for each pH
unit should be about 60 millivolts if
you start at pH 7 if you notice the
millivolt reading force pH 7 should
ideally be zero millivolts with plus or
minus 15 as Lori mentioned before each
pH unit higher than 7 will decrease by
about 60 millivolts and each pH unit
lower than 7 will increase by about 60
millivolts so as you can see here pH 4
is ideally around
180 millivolts and ph9 is ideally around
one negative 120 millivolts the voltage
is measured after three minutes in a
stirred solution and is used as a
comparison value for determining the
response time the response time is the
time after which the measured voltage
has reached this comparison value within
plus or minus 1 millivolt reading the
maximum permitted response time of the
peel pH electrode is about 60 seconds if
the response time exceeds 60 seconds you
may want to consider replacing your
electrode
number two check the potential offset if
you're experiencing results that are off
whether they're higher or lower than
normal or they're beginning to shift
consider testing your electrodes
potential offset this is the difference
of your electrode is measuring versus
the ideal millivolt reading of a buffer
first perform the millivolt measure of
pH 7 buffer next evaluate is your
measurement within the offset limits
depending on the type of electrode
you're working with you may have
different offset limits
you may also measure
difference between pH 7 buffer and the
pH 4 buffer just repeat the previous
procedure to determine the millivolt
measurement for pH 4 determine the
difference between pH 7 millivolt
reading and the pH 4 millivolt reading
consider replacing the electrode if the
difference is considerably higher or
lower than 150 millivolts thirdly check
the calibration slope remember a good
calibration slope is necessary to
correlating the correct pH value to the
millivolt signaled electrode if you're
uncertain if your electrode is past
retirement perform a quick calibration
and take a look at the calibration slope
consider your replacing your electrode
if your slope is consistently lower than
95 percent or higher than 103 percent to
refer to the slope after calibration
with the touch control it can be found
in the calibration data of your
particular sensor in siamo you can find
the slope is listed in the sensors
window of the configuration tab number 4
check just
streaming potential drift is a signal
change in a stirred solution over a
period of time we usually recommend
three minutes the streaming potential is
the difference of measured signals in a
stirred solution versus a non stirred
solution for each electrode status as
listed the maximum permitted drift in a
stirred solution and the maximum
streaming potential consider electrode
replacement if you're observing a drift
of greater than three millivolts per
minute and a streaming potential greater
than four millivolts per minute number
five inspect regularly we heard earlier
how important the membrane and diaphragm
are making accurate measurements I would
encourage you to get familiar with these
key parts of your electrode pull them
out and inspect them ensure there aren't
any any cracks it's good practice to
inspect them before every time your you
use them here we see an electrode
been put away with the fill port plug
open and not in the storage solution
what we end up with is an electrode
within a with a reference system that is
completely non-functional you can try to
revive it by rinsing the outside with
warm water empty and flush the inside of
the electrode with the electrolyte fill
solution and remember do not use water
and store the electrode overnight in the
storage solution after all this I would
still recommend going back and
performing a calibration check to verify
that it was permanently damaged
hopefully these tips will help you
determine when your electrode needs
replacement and as in a summary
understanding how electrodes work always
allows you to perform better inspection
inspection and understand important
calibration results simple electrode
check and calibration tests can reveal
the health of the electrode and quickly
indicate if replacement is needed and
finally depending on usage and care
common to replace electrode every six
months to one year views so Lori's got a
few more things to go over before we
finish with the Q&A so I'm going to go
ahead and hand it back over to her thank
you
Thank You Jessica so because there are
some electrical components in the
electrode head we often get asked if we
can help ensure responsible disposable
disposal of exhausted electrodes so for
that I'm happy to say that we can help
if you have old electrodes and you need
to dispose of them and you want to
ensure that it's being done responsibly
you can ship them to us and we're happy
to take care of that the only thing I'll
ask is that just ensure that you've
emptied the electrode solution from the
body and please address the shipment to
Metro USA electrode disposal program you
can package and ship the item to the
address on your screen
lastly if you need more information you
know if you'd like a little bit more
informative session or you want that
direct access to some of our experts
we're going to continue to extend our
below the surface seminar series with
four more dates in all new locations so
if you head out to seminars met room
usa.com
you'll be able to access the
registration for this free event so now
I'd like to hand it back to our
moderator for the live Q&A session
excellent thank you very much and for
those of you that may have joined us
late if you have any questions for Lori
or Jessica you can ask them simply by
typing your query into the question box
which is located at the bottom left-hand
side of your screen so the first
question that I have for you is how
often do we need to replace our pH
electrodes yeah so you know if this is
one of those questions that's always we
get asked it a lot and Jessica kind of
summed it up for us as a general rule of
thumb to not be shocked if you need to
replace your electrode every 6 to 12
months all of this of course is
depending on how it's cared for how many
measurements you're making I mean we
have some locations that are measuring
making hundreds of measurements a day
and some that make a few a month so
usage will play a lot into that
replacement factor as well as how you're
able to care for it excellent thank you
now how is the electrode ph measuring
capability changed by storing it in
water um you know so for that really the
reason why we say to stay away from
storing it and water is because what
you're going to do is end up drawing the
electrolyte out of the reference system
so that salt saturated solution would
love to be dissolved in water so what
you're going to do is really just put
more more where on that reference system
okay excellent
now what to mean by the electric light
level being too low to me below the
sample level yeah yeah that's that's
exactly right
I think I don't know if it's helpful to
jump back out to that slide where we
were having that discussion so so
believe this was the slide we were
looking at and yes so the the image on
the left where were at section a that
the the sample once the electrode is
submerged into the sample that would
mean the sample volume is actually
higher than where the electrolyte volume
is in the electrode so you're on the
right track with that so definitely keep
it filled higher to avoid that
contamination excellent Thank You Nora
next question s is it okay to dry the
tip of the electrode with a kimwipe
after rinsing with distilled water no we
really really try to get people not to
do that so sometimes I know that we fear
that extra that extra drip hanging on
the bulb is going to somehow our next
sample or dilute our next measurement
really if you could just give give it
kind of just a tap just a light tap of
your finger to knock that that drop off
that's really best practices chem whites
can be can have a lot of static or be
very harsh when they come in contact
with the membrane so as best we can try
not to do that I know there are some
customers out there for some some folks
out there listening now that say hey
listen I I cannot I you know I got to
keep this clean and my samples are just
really really difficult so we can
definitely definitely try to work with
you to help come up with an alternate
you know solution just overall really
try to avoid that
thank you and our next question would it
be better to warm or cool buffers to a
similar temperature of sample or warm
elect the electrode in the sample and
use room-temperature buffers can you
repeat that question for me
sure would be better to use to warm or
cool buffers to a similar temperature of
the sample or warm the electrode in the
sample and use room-temperature buffers
okay so so when it comes to to
temperature what we want to do is to
measure the buffers at room temperature
we don't want it we don't want to heat
anything either side electrodes or
buffers per se what we want to do is
with your buffers there will be a
calibration table or a buffer table with
temperatures so we need to tell the
system what temperature we plan to
perform the calibration that so that's
kind of where we're going to go with
that the rule kind of general rule of
thumb is that we'd like to make sure
that our calibration temperature and our
sample temperatures are in alignment if
you're using a pH electrode with a built
in temperature sensor this is really the
most convenient so it will automatically
continuously make sure that that
temperature adjustment is made in the pH
value that we report back out so
hopefully that was helpful yes thank you
now the next question as does both the
tip and diaphragm need to be submerged
in the sample to get an effective
reading or just the tip we recommend
here is I you do need the tip and the
diaphragm submerged into your bust
buffer or sample at the time of
measurement so the answer would be yes
the diaphragm and the bulb
excellent no our next question has to do
with routine cleaning do you recommend
that be done once a week or once a month
is there a recommendation there yeah I
mean so again this is really going to
come down to how much are you using it
you know if you're getting you're doing
a lot of measurements multiple let's say
you know if you're making more than 10
measurements a day and that electorate
is in high youth it's probably a good
idea to make sure that you are are
making you're at least inspecting it to
make sure that it needs doesn't need to
be clean when we look at the the routine
cleaning of exchanging that electrolyte
what we're doing there is preventing the
electrolyte concentration inside of the
chamber from increasing so we often see
the who begin to see it salt out that
means that the electrolyte concentration
of that is changing and we need to keep
that system as steady as possible so
keep an eye on those things once per
week and if you find that you know maybe
you can go every other week that would
also be appropriate excellent thank you
I know our next question has to do with
storage recommendations and and why are
long-term storage recommendations why do
they differ from short-term storage for
metal probes mm-hmm so on this one we're
dealing we're talking specifically about
metal pros so if you've got a electrode
that is basically two metal sheets so
think no reference electrode electrolyte
solution this is something that we can
store dry so those metal surfaces don't
need any contact with moisture or
reference electrode so this is going to
be something that would you would use
maybe in a vitamin C application so
think raid offs to platinum sheet tip
electrodes on the flip side we could
have a metal electrode that has a metal
ring and has a reference solution so
this would be kind of a combination
system
that electrode needs to be stored in
reference solutions though right here
the only the only you know factor that
we have to to take care of here is
ensuring the reference doesn't dry out
again that metal ring doesn't need any
particular attention and then we have a
third scenario where you have a metal
ring electrode that has a glass ball now
in those configurations and that type of
a sensor the glass bulb is what we have
to consider storing so just like your pH
measurement your pH electrodes that bulb
needs to stay hydrated
again disregards the metal metal does
not care if it's stored dry or what not
that electrode you would store in water
so hopefully I didn't add any to the
confusion but if there's follow-up
questions we're happy to continue to the
discussion after the live session
excellent thank you
now our next question has to do with
calibrating and how often do you
recommend calibration we recommend
calibrating every day that you're using
your pH meter and your electrode if
you're not using it for the day you
won't have to bother bother calibrating
it but if you are using your lecture
that day we do recommend calibrating it
just for a pH measurement if you're
titrating then you won't really need to
count you won't need to calibrate your
pH electrode if
however if you are having problems with
your titration we do recommend
performing a calibration in regards to
troubleshooting your electrode thanks 1
thank you
now our next question asks are there any
checks I can do for my platinum and
silver ring electrodes yeah so I believe
that is one of the resources that is
attached to this session so there is an
application bullet in there that walks
you through how to perform an electrode
check for those metal electrodes so
great crest great question
go out to that resources tab and
download that information excellent
thank you
now our next question says how often or
how do you know when to empty the
electrode and not just top it off are
the electrolyte and not just top it off
sure so so when it comes down to down to
that I guess you know when you're in
everyday use if you continue to just top
it off that's something that you really
should just give it a peak every day and
just have a squirt bottle beside there
and and top it off on the daily if it
has been left open for an extended
period of time so if so port was left
open overnight or maybe over a long
weekend or something you may you may
need to look a little closer and make
sure that we haven't developed salt
crystals around that top portion or on
the inside of the electrode so once it's
developed on the inside we definitely
need to go ahead and get those removed
and completely empty and refresh it
excellent thank you
now can you explain again why storing
the electrode in potassium chloride
solution is not OK
sure so does that slide I think if I
bump out to it it would be it would be
really helpful here
yeah I think we're pushing it like here
so here in this in this instance it's
not necessarily stirring it in in the
KCl we're talking about long-term
storage so if we go back to this ones
this is a scenario when the electrode
has been kept overnight in a KCl
solution and the reason we don't want to
do this is because those potassium ions
will take up space in the membrane of
the the electrode and in order for us to
be up and running quickly we've got to
get those flushed out so we need the
hydrogen ions to be moving back and
forth across that membrane and it's
potassium is in the way we're not going
to get a very good accurate measurement
so that's the reason we really avoid
staying keeping the electrodes stored in
that kcl solution